while many traditional activities
require face-to-face interactions takuji
rouhani yagi and his students are
learning that putting a screen between
them won't necessarily push them apart
or mcaren Authority equitable because of
coronavirus kids cannot go outside
adults in Japan may be asked to stay
indoors in the future too but culture
shouldn't stop because of the virus I
started taking internet lessons because
it became difficult to go out but I
found it's not as inconvenient as I
imagined for musicians and other stage
performers who earn all of their income
from live performances the cuts dig deep
justin Trat look and the common goods
live audiences aren't in Washington DC
bars these days they're on Facebook by
taking tips on venmo and PayPal they're
making up for some lost revenue fans say
they're also providing a public service
I think that we're bringing something to
people that is creating a little bit of
levity in their lives where they might
all be a little stressed otherwise you
know we're going to the grocery store
and people are people are fighting over
you know the last ream of toilet paper
people are a little bit more worked up
than they are normally in life in dance
classes to rock performances church
choir rehearsals and Shakespeare DJ sets
or the weekly picnic with the girls you
refuse to cancel people everywhere are
carrying on their daily routine online
from going to work to streaming a
favorite show or film our consumption of
streaming content is going through the
roof European regulators called on
streaming Giants to ease up on the
burden the increased traffic puts on
telecommunications networks Netflix and
YouTube have decided to limit access to
high-definition content to a continent
of customers Netflix says it will reduce
quality for all of Europe for 30 days
that should eliminate a quarter of its
traffic the provider takes up nearly 13
percent of all Internet traffic followed
by YouTube with all web streaming
services combined it's estimated that
demand will rise up to 60 percent
because of coronavirus isolation
measures Netflix has lost market share
in recent years to the other services
who are taking their own approach Disney
released the latest installment of Star
Wars 2 it's streaming service early NBC
Universal decided to throw out the rule
book completely streaming films while
they're still in theaters the industry
standard was to wait around 90 days
before going from theater seat to the
couch at home box office receipts have
collapsed the worst in more than 20
years many major blockbusters have
delayed their release until hopefully it
all calms down
Andrew Chappell al Jazeera